this episode was sponsored by ren a
website where you can calculate your
carbon emissions you can also sign up to
make a monthly contribution to offset
your emissions or support rainforest
protection projects
[Music]
tardigrades are famous for their
capacity to survive if you look them up
you will be inundated with long lists of
the many things that scientists have
thrown their way to see if the
tardigrade will survive
we've made some lists like those
ourselves tardigrades on the moon
tardigrades and extreme heat you've
heard about them we've talked about them
what else is there
well here's a surprising fact you might
not have known for certain species of
tardigrades like the one in the middle
of your screen right now you can tell
the difference between a male and a
female by looking
at their toes
that's right the toes
these tardigrades are called malnesium
and the males of these species have a
pair of claws on their feet that are
shaped a little bit differently from the
rest of the claws with only one hook on
each claw instead of the usual two but
after taking a closer peek at this
tardigrade's toes we can confirm that
she is a female tardigrade now that's a
fun fact for us as we watch this clip
but it does not actually do anything for
the poor rotifers that are surrounding
this tardigrade who are currently
stretching themselves in and out of
danger
around the tip of a tardigrade's mouth
are small bumps that we think act like
little sensors and when those bumps make
contact with a rotifer out pops the
tardigrade's stylet a little needle that
pokes out from the tubular mouth opening
that stylet pokes into the rotifer and
from there the tardigrade uses a
circular structure called a pharynx in
its head to create strong suction
and then the stylet goes from
functioning as a needle to functioning
as a portable built-in straw that lets
the tardigrade suck out the inside of
its prey
you can see some of that bodily fluid
leaving the rotifer as the tardigrade
stylet pumps away like a beating heart
and when she is done the rotifer remains
like an empty coffee cup
[Music]
this method of eating works quite well
for the tardigrade letting her eat
quickly from the prey that is directly
in front of her but not all organisms
come equipped with a weapon that lets
them turn rotifers into capri suns these
organisms have to turn to other methods
to extract nutrients from their food
this marine ciliate is called
kentrophilum and it came to james our
master of microscopes in a large
container full of beach sand on a normal
day maybe we would talk more about its
funny almond shape that stretches as it
swims around but today is not a normal
day because this kendra film is about to
be overshadowed by a rotifer
now where is the rotifer you might ask
it is inside the kentrophilum of course
we did not catch the moment of its
capture when the toxic needles lining
the kentrophilum darted out and
paralyzed the rotifer by the time we
arrived the rotifer had already been
ingested
but it was not dead yet
you can see it wiggling and wrestling at
the broad end of the kentro film causing
the ciliate's body to wrinkle and fold
in on itself
but it is trapped inside of a food
vacuole now a compartment that exists
to break this rotifer down
sure the rotifer can try and fight
against the walls of the vacuole holding
it hostage but there's not much it can
do against the digestive enzymes pouring
in or the increasing acidity of its
surroundings a food vacuole is a hostile
place to be and for minutes its
destructive tools will go to work
in the end the rotifer will be left in
dissolved pieces to be absorbed by the
kentrophilum cytoplasm sustaining the
organism that was the site of its last
battle
it's a lonely death for the rotifer with
only the kentrophilum to witness it
though i suppose now there is also us
sharing and immortalizing that rotifer's
final moments
and if the rotifer had not died in the
body of another organism it may have
ended up like this gastric trick not to
be fair they did find themselves in a
very similar situation they are both
dead but the rotifer was eaten alive
digested from the outside while trapped
in another organism meanwhile this
castra trick is going through the exact
opposite situation it is being eaten
from the inside out by a scavenger
called a paranoia
now as far as we know the paranoia
didn't do anything to kill the
gastrotrick it was likely already dead
that we don't know what killed it but
the paranoia is both a hunter and a
scavenger sometimes it can be found with
other paranoia as they hunt down prey in
a pack of hungry microbes
at other times the paranoia scavenges
they are notorious for being able to
squeeze their way into whatever holes
they find to get into a dead organism
and in this case the gastritrix
exoskeleton was the right combination of
available open and dead for the
paranormal which found its way in and
decided to begin helping itself to the
buffet of dead tissue around it
after all the gastrotrick won't be
needing that tissue anymore so the
paranoia might as well make good use of
it
the gastrotrick's body has likely
vanished by now perhaps the per animal
will have finished it off entirely or
some other scavenger will have joined in
on the fun
or perhaps it will have simply faded
like the rotifer inside the kentrophilum
its body eventually fading into the
world that encapsulates it
but for this last moment let's remember
the gastrotrick in a more beautiful
moment under a fluorescent light
glowing and the glorious purple
autofluorescence of its remains
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you again to ren for
sponsoring this episode of journey to
the micro cosmos ren is a website where
you can calculate your carbon emissions
then offset them by funding projects
like community tree planting in east
africa or a project that uses satellite
monitoring and drones to detect and
prevent deforestation in the amazon
rainforest we will need a lot of
different approaches to take on the
climate crisis and this is one way that
you can learn more about your carbon
contribution and take some action you'll
answer a few questions about your
lifestyle and they'll also show you ways
you can start reducing your carbon
emissions no one can reduce their
footprint to zero but when using ren you
can offset what you have left once you
sign up you'll receive updates from the
tree planting rainforest protection and
other projects you support and we've
partnered with ren to protect an extra
10 acres of rainforest for the first 100
people who sign up using our link in the
description
there's a group of people in the world
and their names are on the screen right
now who really you know rather like
chill videos about tardigrades sucking
the insides out of rotifers they are our
patrons on patreon they're the kind of
people who think to themselves you know
i would really like for this kind of
content to exist and so they give us a
little bit of money every month so that
we can keep doing it and we really
definitely could not do it without them
if you would like to become one of those
people you can do that at patreon.com
journey2micro and if you'd like to see
more from our master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on instagram or on tiktok and if
you want to see more from us i bet you
there is a subscribe button somewhere
nearby